in many cities in america gun violence
is on the rise including in new york
where thousands of police officers lined
the streets to say goodbye after two
officers were shot to death in an ambush
the gun used to kill the officers was a
glock 45 equipped with an illegal
modified drum magazine that could hold
50 rounds
joe biden was in new york on thursday
touring communities on the front lines
of gun violence
america's murder rate has jumped nearly
30 percent in recent years and gun sales
have soared since the start of the
pandemic
in the u.s more than 30 police officers
have been shot so far this year
biden toured new york's police
headquarters where he rejected calls
from some in his party to rein in police
spending the answer is not to defund the
police
it's to give you the tools the training
the funding
to be partners that's why i called on
the congress to pass a budget
later this year that provides cities
like new york and others with an
additional 300 million dollars
for community policing
but already the budget of the new york
police department
the largest in the u.s is 10 billion
dollars a year if we start defining
public safety though in terms of how
much money we spend on policing that's
the wrong approach
we should be asking for metrics that
measure community well-being
safety
school attendance employment all the
things that we care about in a
neighborhood should be the way we define
safety not simply how much we're
spending on policing or how many
officers there are in the city on
thursday president biden announced new
initiatives to try to slow down gun
violence including the launching of five
illegal gun task forces meant to try to
stop the flow of illegal guns traveling
between different states
new york's mayor eric adams points to
the so-called iron pipeline the name
given by law enforcement to a loose
connection of highways from the southern
u.s to the northeast
used by gun smugglers to move weapons
we're going to break and destroy the
iron pipeline that allows southern
states in this country to produce
weapons that end up on the streets and
take the lives of our police officers
but community advocates say biden and
adams policies just focus on more police
we can overplease communities
particularly communities of color and
think that this is going to be the
solution it's short-sighted it's an old
practice and tactic that adam's
the mayor
wants to take on
and it really focuses on incarcerating
or
bringing those policing tactics into
mostly communities of color everyone
agrees the violence needs to stop the
question is only how best to do it
gabriel rosando al jazeera new york
[Music]